Yeah,
yes,
it was there that I
decided
that even if I wasn't going to die,
and obviously I didn't.
I'm not afraid of death.
The is part of life.
Most people I have met a particularly.
Americans
just are so afraid of death.
Um,
I don't look forward to it at 85.
I know it's just a few years away,
but I don't fear it.
I believe in the afterlife,
I believe,
and a reward and punishment and I hope
I'll be rewarded.
I think some of all of that comes from
having served in
war.
Um,
and I think I'm serving in a war and
seeing people die,
um,
also impacts on how you think about
other wars.
So I believe,
uh,
that this country has to be defended and
air are just wars.
And certainly World War Two was a such a
just war,
uh,
but that the Vietnam War was not.
And I thought that we shouldn't be in
it.
And I was marching the various
demonstrations against it.
Uh,
I,
uh,
believed it was wrong and ultimately I'm
a huge majority of the people of this
country thought it was wrong.
And,
uh,
they stopped it with their marches.
Well,
I think like most soldiers at the time,
I served in the European theater of
operations and served into campaigns,
one for northern France,
the other for the Rhineland and I fought
in Holland,
Belgium,
Germany.
Um,
I saw people killed.
I was very frightened and often thought
I would
probably die,
uh,
in Europe on the battlefield somewhere,
but I didn't.
And uh,
I came out alive.
I was discharged as a sergeant.
Uh,
um,
I think that being in a war and has an
effect on your character
outlook on life.
And,
uh,
I don't recommend it,
certainly other ways to build character.
Um,
but it's part of who you are,
what you are.